-Hey, guys. I'm here
with Justin Bieber,
and we're gonna play
some hockey,
or as they call it
in Canada...?
-Hockey.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Okay, let's do this.
Why do we need all this stuff?
This is the dumbest thing.
-So, imagine a puck,
which is like really hard,
you know, it's like what
a puck is, right?
[ Chuckles ]
Why do you look at me
so dumb?
-Who's your favorite
hockey player?
-Probably Alexander Nordique.
-He's cool?
-No, I just made him up.
He's not really a player.
♪♪
There you go. You're all
dressed up, ready to go?
-Yeah.
Actually, I'm not kidding.
I have to go to the bathroom.
I really do.
-So, you're gonna push off
with your right
and then push this way.
This way.
Do you feel like
you're getting it?
-Oh, yeah.
Don't you feel like it?
Oh, no. I think I'm getting it.
I get it now.
It's like pizza, French fries,
pizza, French fries.
-No, that's skiing.
So that has nothing to --
You keep going backwards.
I don't know why
you keep going --
-That's so weird.
-So, you're gonna go
red line, stop,
blue line, stop,
all the way down.
Then all the way back.
So go ahead.
Go.
[ Laughter ]
Red line.
Yeah. Stop.
Alright, come back
to the blue line.
[ Laughs ]
Alright, stop. Yep.
Then you go all the way down.
All the way down.
Stand up.
-Just pull me.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
We made it.
So, you're gonna go in and out
of the pylons,
go outside, inside,
outside, inside, outside.
You got this.
-Easy peasy.
Here we go, dudes.
Yo, dudes, what's up?
[ Laughter ]
Alright, Wait. I have an idea.
I have an idea.
-Okay.
-Can you just stand here
for one second?
-Inside, outside.
Inside, outside.
-So, I'm gonna show you how to
do a simple backhand shot.
-Why don't we do
backhand shots
and backhanded compliments,
okay?
-Sure. Why not?
Have you lost weight?
You look a lot better than
the last time I seen you.
-I really like your mustache.
I love that it's not
quite skeevy.
Alright, it's shootout time.
This is our goalie Rob.
We have five pucks.
Whoever gets the most in wins.
We're going head-to-head,
stick-to-stick.
-Don't say that.
-Head-to-head
or stick-to-stick?
-Neither.
[ Whistle blows ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Here comes the Irishman.
Here we go.
Alright.
Ee-oo-oo-oo-oo-oo.
Stay up, Jimmy.
Stay up and -- Yeah!
Oh, well...
What you got, Justin?
[ Buzzer ]
Oh, my gosh.
We're rolling?
Oh, we cut.
You're over there.
Cut.
God dang it!
I still can't score.
Good luck.
Oh!
[ Laughs ]
That's gonna haunt
your dreams.
♪ Baby ♪
♪ Shark doo-doo, doo-doo,
doo-doo ♪
♪ Baby shark, doo-doo,
doo-doo, doo-doo ♪
♪ Baby shark ♪
Baby shark!
[ Whistle blows ]
[ Buzzer ]
Oh, my gosh!
Oh! [ Laughs ]
Oh, my God.
You are so good.
-♪ O Canada ♪
♪ Our home and native land ♪
♪ True patriot love ♪
♪ In all thy sons command ♪
-You are the best,
Justin Bieber!
[ Cheers and applause ]